abone ol
[Müzik]
e
herkese merhaba
yıllar sonra
çocukluğunun ve gençliğinin geçtiği çok
sevdim Okulu'nda olmak çok çok güzel bir
duygu
Selam bu gün sizlere
o kadın ve erkekten bahsedeceğim
bildiğimiz ve bilmediğimiz tarihin ilk
anlarından itibaren hep süre gelen bir
soru Kadın nedir erkekmidir Ne kadar
farklılar ne kadar benzerler
burada bir resmi görüyorsunuz Fransız
ressam şarj jozef notaların 1740 yılında
yaptım
şıma Adem'le Havva'nın Tanrı'dan azar
işitip sonra da Cennetten kovulduğunu
anlatan bir resim
çok ilginç bir detayı var hava çok
düzgün ağlıyor orada Kösem köşede
çaresiz Adem s
bu işi çözebileceğini düşünüyor Belli ki
Muhtemelen havaya söylemiş Dur bir
dakika herhalde halledeceğim demiş orada
yalvarıyor
Ya aslında Yüzyıllardır
toplumun bize Belki bir yıllardır
çizdiği rol tam olarak da bu kadınlar
genelde mağdur genelde güçsüz daha az
şey yapabiliyor erkeklere göre
ama bazı konularda yeterli değiller
zaten
ya ben bugün sizlere
bu bizim için en bu rolün dışına nasıl
çıkabiliriz
bu ve asla içinizdeki gücü nasıl ortaya
çıkarabiliriz bazı tecrübelerini
paylaşarak
33 Ören diğim gördüm Bu noktayı sizlerle
de paylaşacağım
11sınıf
bu ne yapıp Neyi yapamayacağı mıza ancak
biz karar verebilir
ama hepimiz
bu Burada sadece kadınlar kızlar da
değil erkeklerde
ve sürekli onu yapamazsın yeterli mısın
acaba Bence onu deneme bunu dene gibi
O çok fazla
yönlendirme ile karşılaşıyoruz
ama ben size altta ortada oturan kızın
hikayesini anlatacağım
ama biz okula başladığımızda o zamanlar
8 yıllık eğitim yoktu
bu
rapte başlıyorduk Lise sona kadar yedi
yıl hep birlikteyiz çok güzel Eminim şu
anda da öyledir yemekler çaylar
çardaklar
Eğlence bol bir okulumuz hep oldum çok
ama çok ilginç bir
Bu ortamımız da vardı Şöyle ki şimdi
gerçi 60 kız 60 erkek
kalınıyor eşit sayılar bizim dönemimizde
öyle değildi erkekler nedense daha
sayıda fazlaydı ve okula adım
attığımızda ilk andan itibaren bize hep
şu anlatıldı Burası Aslında erkek okul
uymuş Burası Ancak ve ancak 80'lerden
sonra kız öğrencileri kabul etmeye
başlamış
bu peki Yani çok bir şey ifade etmiyordu
Aslında bu bizler için
var Ama zamanla hani bunun ne anlama
geldiğini küçük örnekler de detaylarda
yaşayarak görmeye başladık
ve bu bahsettiğim yemeklerimizi
çaylarımızı hep erkek arkadaşlarımız
organize ediyordu Nedenini bilmiyorum ta
ki orta son mezuniyetimize kadar biz bir
grup kız arkadaşlar bunu bizim organize
edelim Neden olmasın Kill 1996
ama biz ortaokuldan mezun oluyoruz çok
heyecanlıyız Hadise devam edeceğiz Ama
yine de bizim için çok önemli bir adım
gittik
bu otellerde restoranlarda konuştuk çok
güzel bir program hazırladık fiyatlarını
çıkardık çok Emeğiniz çok mutlu çok
görürüz planımız dan programında Tabii
en çok karşılaşılan bir durum değil o
yüzden dönem olarak bu konuda bir oylama
yapılmasına karar verdik
E tabii ki rakibimiz erkek
arkadaşlarımız Biz de 4-5 tane kız bir
program yapmışız
Bu kampanyamızda seçim kampanyanızı
başladık konuşmaya başladık
arkadaşlarımızı anlatıyoruz neler
planladık neler hazırladık ne yapmak
istiyoruz fiyatı nedir bayağı ciddi
ciddi Hedef kitlenizi belirleyip
kampanyamızı yürüttük sonrasında
bu oynamaya geldi sıra
bu seçme yapacağız ev kaldıracağız en
çok oyu alan grup yemeği organize etmeye
hak kazanacak Peki çok güzel
var mı o gün o seçimde
bu bizim için el kaldıranlar sayıda
fazlaydı ve okul tarihinde ilk defa bir
yemeği bir kız grubu organize edecekti
Ben 10 ki duygularımı inanın size
anlatamam ve
ve o anki
duygularımın bende yarattığı o
Özgüven de diyebilirsiniz mutluluk da
diyebilirsiniz
ve o heyecan yıllar boyu kaldı ve birçok
konuyu adım atabilme mi sağladı
Bu üniversite girişinde birileri bana
yan puanı yetiyorsa işletme-iktisat seç
Mühendislik çok kızlara göre değil
dediğinde ya da çocuğum olduğundan ya
Hem yoğun çalışıp hem çocuk yani Çok
kolay değil bir istersen değerlendir
dediğinde ya da
Bu üçüncü çocuğu hamile kaldığında artık
yani hani mümkün değil bunlar yürümez
dendiğinde
mı böyle bir Hani içimden kız kız gülüm
başıma çevirip gidebilme mi sağlayan
belki de o anki o duyguydu
sonrasında yemek nasıl geçti derseniz
geçmedi yemek Çünkü
saçımdan sonra sınıf abimiz yanımıza
gelip kızar Tebrikler seçildiniz ama
biliyorsunuz Bizim okulumuzda yemekleri
erkekler organize ediyor O nedenle
maalesef siz yapacaksınız dedi ve biz o
yemeyi organize edemedik nihayetinde Bu
da başka bir şeyin örneği
bu maalesef bireysel başarılar her zaman
bizi sonra götürmeye biliyor
ve toplumsal olarak bu farkındalığı bu
ilerlemeyi sağlamamız gerekiyor O da
tabi bambaşka bir konu
bu sütünden farklı bir bilgi de
paylaşmak istiyorum mutlulukla ilgili bi
şimdi eskiden ailelere sorduklarında
nasıl Çocuklar yetiştirmek istiyorsunuz
çocuğunuzun Nasıl olmasını istiyorsunuz
dediklerinde herkes Tabii ki de başarılı
çocuklar olmasını istiyoruz
değerlendirir sonra bu zaman içerisinde
özgüvenli çocuğa evrilmiş Herkes her
aile özgüvenli çocuklar yetiştirmek
istemiş çocuklar için en iyisi ne
olduğunu düşünür şimdilerde sorulduğunda
herkes mutlu çocuklar yetiştirmek
istiyor
bu çocuklarımız için en önemli şey mutlu
olmak olduğunu düşünüyoruz Hakikaten de
öyle baktığımızda Yani bir başı ve sonu
olan bir hayat sürüyoruz istersek
tanışın olan istersek dünyanın öbür
ucunda
ve geçirdiğimiz süre Aslında oradaki
sürede ki mutluluk o hayatı anlamlı
kılar
bu ve burada bir mutluluk indeksini
paylaşıyorum sizlerle bakmışlar
dünyadaki en mutlu ülkeden hangileri
bu burada ilk onun ülkeyi
paylaşıyorum sıralamaya söyle baktım
inanın Türkiye'yi göremedim ilk 60-70
içerisinde Burada maalesef
bu ve acaba Neden sorusunu sorduğumda
birçok Tabii ki neden olabilir işte
gelir seviyesi olabilir gelişmişlik
Eğitim Bir sürü neden olabilir o çok
ilginç bir detayla yan yana getirdim
bunu kadın erkek eşitliğinde x en
güvendiği Pi'nin Birleşmiş Milletler
gelişim programının
yürüttüğü bir jennerin 26 index kadın
erkek eşitsizlik indeksinde orada bütün
ülkeler işte bir puanlandırma yapıyorlar
en düşük puanı alan en iyi durumda olan
şu yandaki ülkelerde her birinin oradaki
yerini yazdım çok ilginçtir Tabii ki
bile bir korelasyon yok ama bütün
Bu ip puanları almış olan ülkeler
bu Türkiye maalesef burada 68 sırada
o orada gidecek yolumuz var dedi ki
bu burada bu datanın yanına farklı
şeyler de getirebilir dikse kişi başına
düşen milli gelir
gelişmişlik endeksi eğitim seviyesi gibi
şeyler ama bu tek başına şunu gösteriyor
orta toplum olarak önce eşitlikle
başlamamız gerekiyor hani sadece kadın
erkek eşitliğinde değil aslında belki
Hani insan olarak herkesin her bir
bireyin aynı imkanlara aynı şartlara
sahip olabilmesi aynı adımları
atabilecek gücü kendinde bulabilmesi bu
da özgürlükleri geçiyor özgürlükler
ekonomik ve sosyal gelişimi bu da
nihayetinde büyük ihtimalle mutluluğa
bize getiriyor dur
o orada Türkiye olarak asla hepimize Bu
salonda bulunan bulunmayan bütün
gençlerimize patch çok ciddi işler
düşüyor Bu hepimizin kadınlar erkekler
olarak aynı yöne doğru ilerlememiz ancak
gerçekleşti ikincisi
Bu Hayat gerçekten yeterince karmaşık
bir zar daha öğrencilik yıllarımızda
bunu görüyorsunuz dur o dersler bu
devasa dersler dediği yapmak istediğiniz
onlarca çekmeyin vardır bir hayat
ileride daha da karmaşık ulaşıyor
bu işin içine iş kariyer aile bu
bambaşka
değişkenler faktörler giriyor ve
hakikaten çok karmaşık bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz ve dünyada karmaşıklık ta Gün
geçtikçe artıyor burada 1970'ten mm
yılına kadar bir araştırma yapmışlar
bu well-being indeksi ölçmüşler
kadınlarda ve erkeklerde bel birinden
kasıt insanın kendini iyi hissetmesi
hayatından memnun olması aslında pembe
çizgi kadınları diğer siyah çizgi
erkekleri gösteriyor Bu Amerika'da
yapılan bir analiz Ama büyük ihtimalle
dünyanın birçok yerinde benzerdir
Hoş gördük 2990 yılından sonra çok ciddi
bir kırılma olmuş öncesinde insanlar
şişte mutluyuz yani fena değil
hayatımızdan memnunuz danken
1990'lardan sonra bu negatife dolmuş
insanlar daha stresli muhtemelen daha
karmaşık hayatlarını etkisiyle
memnuniyetleri hayatlarında
memnuniyetleri ciddi oranda düşmüş ve bu
da İlginç olan kadınlar için bu düşük
erkeklere göre çok daha hızlı ve çok
daha büyük oranda olmuş
burada ilginç bir bilgi de paylaşmak
istiyorum
bu piramitleri inşa ederken o
inşaatlarda çalışan Mısır'daki eski
antik Mısır'daki işçiler yılda 130 bir
gün Günde altı ila 8 saat arası
çalışıyorlarmış bugün teknoloji
sektöründe yeni işe başlayan bir kişi
yılda en az 200 40 gün Günde en az 11 12
saat çalışıyor Hani bazen kendi hızlı
konuşuyoruz köyde gibi çalışıyoruz diye
Köle gibi çalışmıyoruz ya Muhtemelen
köleler bizim kadar çalışsam İsyan
ederlerdi
Dolayısıyla bu karmaşık dünyada giderek
karmaşıklaşan hayatta
Ne yapmamız gereken seçimler var Her şey
mükemmel yapamayız kendimizden mükemmel
olmayı beklememiz gerekiyor
bu hem
ve her derste aşırı derecede başarılı
olayım Daha sonrasında her elimi attığım
işte son derece başarılı olayım güzel
kalayım zayıf olayım Evimde her gün beş
öğün yemek yapayım Her yaprağın Bu
mümkün değil Herşey yetişmemiz mümkün
değil kendimizden beklentilerimiz de
sınırlama mız gerekiyor ki asıl yapmak
istediğimiz zevk aldığımız şeylere zaman
kalsın Hani bu
bu para TOBB kuralı vardır 80'e 20
bu derslerde de yine bir oranda
kesinlikle uygulanabilir şunu söylüyor
parata kuralı biliyorsunuzdur belki
Bu bir işin yüzde seksenini yapabilmek
için yüzde yirmi Efor vardır Diğer
harcadığımız yüzde seksen Efor kalan
yüzde yirmi tamamlamaya yeter Bu şu
anlama geliyor bir şey mükemmel yapmak
için O çok ciddi Efor harcımız gerekiyor
bazı şeyleri olduğu kadar ihtiyacı kadar
yapıp gerçekten bize zevk veren Keyif
veren yapmayı sevdiğiniz şeylere de
limitli zamanımız ayırmak çok çok önemli
bu üçüncüsü
yok Yalnız Değiliz yardıma ihtiyacımız
olduğunda
yardım isteye bilmeliyiz
ve bu ailemiz olabilir arkadaşlarımız
olabilir
ve bu şunu için çok önemli ama her şey
tek başımıza yapmamız mümkün değil ama
bazen belki eğitim sistemiyle çok
bireysel olduğu için eğitim sistemi
sınava tek başımıza girdiğimiz o
an sadece kendi adımıza onu yaptığımız
için
belki öyle bir sınırlandırma oluyor
aklımızda Ama
hayatta her zaman el ele tutuşan
bilmeliyiz burada çok ilginç bir bilgi
var kadınlar ve erkekler
haklarını isterken ya da yardım isterken
daha farklı davranıyorlar ilk işe
başlayan erkeklerin yüzde 57'si
maaşlarını
bu pazarlığını yapabiliyorlar Daha
yüksek maaşı hak ettiğini düşünüyor ve
bunu açıkça yöneticisine ya da görüştük
kişiye söyleyebiliyor bu oran kadınlarda
sadece yüzde yedi da aynı iş için aynı
yaşta aynı tecrübeyle oraya başvurmuş
olan kişilerde çok ciddi bir fark var
erkeklerde çünkü hep vardır yap daha
iyisini hak ediyorum onu yapabilirim
kadınlar biraz daha
da elimden gelen bu elimden gelenin en
iyisini yapayım eminim sonucu da
gelecektir gibi yaklaşıyor şu Her zaman
öyle olmayabiliyor maalesef
ya
ben de kendi iş hayatında şunu gördüm
bu ne zaman bir Yardıma ihtiyacım
olduğunda etrafında
o ulaştığım kişiler
yardım ettiler yani Öyle ya da böyle
bu Belki farklı bir zamanı söylediler
Belki bir projenin zamanı için
değişiklik sağladık bu belki bambaşka
bir insanlığı beni tanıştırıp yapmayı
istediğim Aklımdaki projeyi tamamlamalı
sağladılar Ama bu yardımı istediğimizde
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle ona
ulaşabiliyoruz
ve bu yardım konusu ile ilgili çok
ilginç bir
Piranha mı da anlatmak istiyorum Biz
eşimle evlendiğimizde ilk evlendik yıl
2006'da
bu akşam oturuyoruz bana iki Nur sadece
ya bir meyve getirebilir misin dedim
getiririm yani Ama neden Hani sen de
alabilirsin ya hep Annem getiriyordu
bana dedi bana da annem getiriyordu
dedim hani şu an yok Hani Biz kendi
işimizi yapabiliriz
bu soruyu Muhtemelen çok az koca eşinden
duyuyordur bana şunu getirebilir misin
diye ama
Ama biz kendi adımıza ailecek Hani o
düzenimizi zaman içerisinde kurduğumuzu
düşünüyorum
ve her işi hayatta paylaşıyor olmamız
gerekiyor Bunun kadını erkeği yok
olamazda
ve ancak o zaman birbirimize yardım
ederek
bu daha iyisini başarabilirim
bu ve bir diğer önemli nokta da nasıl
Bizler hayatta yardım aldıysak eğitim
Konusunda kariyer konusunda en önemli
şey bizden sonra gelenlere de yardım
edebilmek
burada bu odada bulunan herkes çok
şanslı
bu eğitimim açısından aldıkları destek
açısından maalesef toplumunda o kadar
şanslı olmayan kesimler çok çok fazla ve
Elimizi uzatabiliyor olmamız gerekiyor
Bu el uzatmak Aslında çoğu zaman
cesaretlendirme de olabilir Ben şu
örneklerle çok karşılaştım şu
ya bir arkadaşım iş arkadaşım kadın çok
güzel bir iş yapmış Harika ya Daha önce
yapılmamış belki Hani dünyada dahi
yapılmış bir iş ama yok ya ben bunu
sunmak istemiyorum Biraz utanıyorum çok
iyi değil bence
ben onu Bak yarısı kadar olamayacak bir
işi başka biri bütün dünyayı anlatırken
orada bir cesaretlendirme ihtiyacı
oluyor Hayır canım ne münasebet bunu sağ
yaptım çok iyi yaptın ve bunu
ama anlatabilirsin insanlara
öğretebilirsin demek bile inanın o
kişinin hayatına dokunmak oluyor
da aynı şekilde kariyer adımlarını
atarken de şunu görüyoruz kadınlar daha
zamanı bekleyeyim
bu şekilde olur herhalde istediğim
şeyler Ben işime odakların derken
erkekler Hep bir sonraki
o zaman Ne zaman bir sonraki terfi ne
zaman gibi daha açık belirte biliyorlar
isteklerini aynı seviyeye gelmemiz
gerekiyor çünkü
isteklerinizi belirtmediğiniz sürece BM
maalesef ilerleyemiyoruz buz son olarak
çok az önce olur abi ile konuşurken
sevgili oluşuyor kanla konuşurken
paylaşınız bilgi sizlerle de paylaşmak
istiyorum
bu dünyada sadece üç dilde Türkçe Fince
ve estonyaca da
o kadın ve erkeğe aynı hitap kelimesi
kullanıyor o
ve diğer her dilde İngilizce'de mesela
biliyorsunuz hişil Türkçede o kadın
erkek ayrı değil Ayna Aslında
Dolayısıyla
bizim kültürümüzün derinliklerinde bizim
varlığımızın benliğinin derinliklerinde
bu eşitlik zaten var
ama Bizler de bunun farkında olarak
bunları Önümüzdeki nesillere de
aktarmalıyız ki daha mutlu daha
en ileri bir toplum olabilirim
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
abone ol